nice i know hey everybody this is my
boyfriend senator robert lipton hi
senator it's an honor i'm angela's
friend oscar
oscar
a pleasure
robert seems great he's very handsome
firm handshake he's gay good sense of
humor
thank you
it's gorgeous angela yeah i actually
know about nice rings and it is gorgeous
it's a little flashy i mean when am i
naomi judd
angela's engaged to a gay man
as a gay man i'm horrified as a friend
of angela's horrified
as a lover of elegant weddings
i'm a little excited
but overall
horrified
hey senator lipton hey how are you you
didn't call me
um
well uh the issue that i that concerned
me you know what this is about
hi
hi
spring cleaning
more like fall cleaning
i think the senator is having an affair
this doesn't
i'm sorry what what i need your help i
need someone who could operate outside
of the law oh i'm sorry your vigilante
privileges ended when you broke up with
me i'm not in your panties i don't go
vigilantes you ask your husband my
marriage is in danger i don't know who i
can trust
i need someone to be there for me
all right what are we talking
surveillance wiretapping something like
that yeah the less i know the better
i know just the guy he was a volunteer
sheriff too kicked off the force can you
arrange a meeting i could try
i'm gonna use sms text
okay
text went through
okay all we can do is sit and wait okay
oh
look at that
yeah he's free anytime so what's the job
murder
okay the oh that's the big one that's
the big m
sandwich delivery
for mr oscar martinez
i
am
oscar martinez no not him not him
outside
outside
you know there's donuts in the break
room
nice
you hired someone to hit me with a pipe
you deserved every bit of it you made my
husband gay
what what i did was wrong and i have to
live with that every day but
your husband is gay and he was gay when
you married him no no
i feel so stupid
i sit next to him every day
you're not stupid
jazz is stupid
jazz is stupid
i mean just play the right notes
thank you stan
honey
look i just want our life to get back to
normal ribbon cuttings charity balls
don't worry i've scheduled a press
conference for later today we just need
to face the cameras together a beloved
public servant and his devoted wife
and move on
all right if i have to be the good wife
i'll be the best damn wife there is
correction
best darn wife
sorry i'm a better wife than that
there have been
some rumors
about my personal life
that i would like to settle
once and for all
as my long-suffering wife can attest
i am gay
senator were you always gay or did your
wife turn you gay
question for the senator's beard
i'll say it again for miss amigos
latinos
yo soy homosexual poor angela
yeah
poor angela
i once believed that a gay person could
be somewhat straight
it wasn't until my marriage to angela
that i realized how
charmless i find the female body oh
always hurts to hear that one
there's someone else
i need to thank his name is oscar
martinez
oscar is the one who opened my eyes to
this who i really am
for the first four oscar is with the
senator too
yes
and i knew it the whole time
i kept the secret i kept the secret so
good
you didn't know
you didn't know
you didn't freaking know but i
knew he knew yes we did it you did it
kevin
yes
oh
i did it
oh i did
self-awareness
i was finally able to find love at long
last
with my
amazing
chief of staff wesley silver what wesley
silver is gay
make a nice couple
is everything okay
no
everything is not okay
county took my cats wait all of them two
sacks worth
a apparently
my apartment complex has rules about how
many pets are too many for a studio
and while i was
out
picking philip up from daycare they
came came into my house
that's that's awful angela i'm so sorry
it's the that lives downstairs
she's this uptight judgmental shrew you
know the type
i've never met anyone like that
and we're gone
and i have no one left
without my cats i am utterly
and completely alone
angela you still have your son
i guess
this is angela
oh
hello miss plonokovsky
uh how can i help you
did my rent check not clear because i
just transferred another 25 to that
account so if there's a problem it's
clearly on your end and you
oh
oh
oh okay good
then um what is this about
no no hey hey no you are out of line
miss plundakovsky no
no you are no you are
evicted fine i didn't want to live in
that cesspool anyway listen
i get my security deposit back yes i do
yes
that is not fair that is not fair
well you know what you have so many
hairs on your chin
the animal control should have taken you
away oh that is very unladylike you are
disgusting
what do you think that was about
tense
are you thinking of going camping
i thought you found nature vulgar well
i've changed my mind
wait a minute angela
you're not thinking of living
in
did you just mind your own business
okay i'm just gonna say this
you're not going to live in a tent oh
god
come stay with me
you don't want me at your place i do
yes not forever
but
until you get back on your feet which
won't be long
it's the least i can do
wow
separate bathrooms
thank you
you're welcome
let's go get philip
and we'll get your stuff
okay get the hell out of that place
are you allowed to have pets
you